All right.
So we've decided that we'll be getting
the earthquake data from the USGS
earthquake catalog API.
And we've got some polished
user interface designs for
our app from our designer,
which means we're ready to get started.
So let's talk about the journey,
we'll be referring to this course
map to track our progress.
In lesson one,
we'll explore the USGS site and
figure out how to request
the data that our app needs.
We'll also learn about the structure in
which the data is returned to us, and
compose a plan for extracting that
data programmatically in code.
In lesson two, we'll start to unpack
the concepts you need to understand
in order to get information from
the Internet into an Android app,
things like permissions on Android,
and doing work on a background threat.
In lesson three, we'll dive into the
whole part if the networking topic and
you'll understand that end to
end path of an http request.
Then we'll update our quick report app
through quest data in the USGS real time
and display the most recent earthquakes
in the world within the app.
Okay, let's take a closer
look at lesson one.
In this lesson, we'll start building our
quake report app in incremental stages.
After you've spent some time
familiarizing yourself with USGS API,
we'll begin to prepare our app to
handle the earthquake information we're
interested in displaying.
You'll import some code that we
provided to get you started and
practice becoming
familiar with code base.
Next, you get some focused Java practice
by writing some utility functions
that will be key to extracting and
formatting the metadata
that we want to display about
each earthquake in our list.
You will then transition
to learning how to properly
post the JSON structure contained
in http response from the server.
And to do this we'll take
a sample response and copy and
paste it into the app, pretending that
we got the response from the internet.
In the latter half of the lesson, we'll
update the list item layout to display
the key meta information about each
quake, things like the magnitude,
location details, date and time.
This will mostly be a review of
concept from the last course, but
this will form a nice foundation so
we can dive deeper into networking
on Android shortly after.
We've got a lot to cover, but
after completing this lesson we hope
you feel comfortable exploring the
Internet for external data resources and
approaching a Web API to figure
out how to request data using it.
Let's get started.